admettre un matin presque ordinaire pour
cette automobiliste
autoradio et caméra embarquée allumée
jusqu'à cet instant
un missile russe vient de tomber à côté
d'une usine
d'autres projectiles s'abattent dans la
ville bilan 14 blessés d'après les
autorités locales
c'est une des villes ukrainiennes
touchées ce matin par une vague de
frappe très intense avec Odessa
zapporija ou Kiev la capitale ciblée par
des drones kamikazes une offensive en
réponse à l’humiliante défaites russes à
Carson la semaine dernière et malgré les
mois provoqués par le missile tombé
mardi dans ce village polonais les
Occidentaux pensent qu'il a été tiré par
les forces ukrainiennes la nouvelle
série de frappes ce matin a encore
affaibli le réseau électrique ukrainien
alors que l'hiver s'installe dans le
pays avec les premiers flocons à Kiev et
une température qui devrait descendre à
moins 10 degrés